[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt wohl doch der amtieren
US-Präsident Joe Biden will mit 80
Jahren weiter an der Macht bleiben
beiden wird voraussichtlich im Kampf um
die Präsidentschaft erneut auf Donald
Trump treffen viel los auch in
Deutschland laut der inserumfrage hat
die Ampel keine Mehrheit mehr im Volk
spannende Gäste habe ich heute abend
auch Edelfeder nzz-redakteur Alexander
Kistler er regt sich auf über die
aktuellen großproteste der letzten
Generation der
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete Ralf Stegner
sieht in Deutschland keine Defizite bei
der Meinungsfreiheit das wird spannend
Klimaforscher Hans von Storch sieht das
etwas anders
und zieht Vergleiche zur corona-pandemie
kann sich vor Zulauf nicht mehr retten
immer mehr Menschen können sich die
Lebensmittel kaum noch leisten und wären
Familien jeden Euro umdrehen müssen
erscheint das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium unter
Robert Habeck als Selbstbedienungsladen
der Spiegel spricht sogar man mag ist
kaum glauben weil es ist der Spiegel von
einer kleinen m Qualität ja recht hat er
nicht nur die Staatssekretäre Michael
Kellner und Patrick reichen sind
verschwägert nein 9 Stellen wurden ohne
Ausschreibung besetzt und es flossen
beratergelder an das Ökoinstitut wo
Verena Graichen als Wissenschaftlerin
arbeitet ein weiteres Mitglied der
Familienbande ist Felix mattes
forschungskoordinator am Ökoinstitut und
gleichzeitig Mitglied in Robert habecks
Kommission Gas und Wärme
mattes ist mit der ehemaligen grünen
umweltssenatorin Regine Günther
verheiratet die zusammen mit Patrick
reichens ehemaligen Geschäft Rainer
Barke die Stiftung Klimaneutralität
leitet
Barke wiederum wurde von Harbeck zum
Sonderbeauftragte für die Deutschen am
liebische Klima und energiekooperation
ernannt er Kissler es ist schwören
erstmal hier einen der Kopf von den
ganzen Namen man sieht ein riesiges
Geflecht fast wie ein Plan was ist denn
da los und Wirtschaftsministerium also
ich muss mich konzentrieren um hier eben
mitzukommen das klang jetzt eben so als
wäre sie personenübersicht eines Shakes
so vor allem miteinander verbandelt sind
und legen am Ende liegen alle tot im
Blut erstochen auf der Bühne
family sondern ja das sind die Tiere
also die schrecklichen Frau oder die
hübschen oder den netten Familie
kreischens drei Geschwister offenbar und
angeheiratet schwippschwäger also
schwägert ja man muss das schon an la
familia denken also an eine
Familienbande und es fällt einem einfach
schwer zu glauben dass ihr wirklich
kompetenzgründer höher gewichtet worden
sein sollen als familiäre Vertrautheit
und das geht natürlich gar nicht man
muss auch den anscheinend meiden den
anscheinend vermeiden dass ihr Vettern
Wirtschaft betrieben würde und diese
anscheinend wird hier zumindest in
keiner Weise Familie einstellen nicht
ausgeschrieben das geht gar nicht
stellen müssen ausgeschrieben weil wenn
die dann die bekommen aufgrund eines
ordentlichen Verfahrens dadurch keiner
was dagegen aber ohne Ausschreibung geht
es nicht und eine solche über
Repräsentanz von einer Familie geht gar
nicht egal in welcher Familie also
welcher Parteienfamilie auch bei der SPD
bei der CSU weil AFD bei wem auch immer
das geschehen wäre das nicht akzeptabel
und meine Verdacht ist halt man lässt es
durch weil man ja das übergeordnete
große Ziel hat wir wollen das
Wirtschaftsministerium umbauen zum
klimaschutzministerium und da brauchen
wir klimaschutzkompetenz und die hole
ich mir bei meinen Leuten und bei meiner
Familie und leider brauchen wir momentan
mehr Wirtschaftskompetenz noch als
klimaschutzkompetenz und wir sehen
aufgrund dieser Familienbande leider
Gottes dass Herr Habig eine schwache
legitimationszeit hat eine schwache
kompetenzseite was die
Wirtschaftspolitik angeht und eine
familiär belastete Kompetenz Seite auf
der Klimaschutzpolitik also ich würde
sagen so geht das nicht es kann nicht
der anscheinend entstehen dass hier ein
Ministerium ein Minister sich die
Stellen zur Beute von Nah und next
stehenden Verwandten Macht bleiben wir
noch mal bei der
Mentalität wie er nicht nur der Spiegel
geschrieben hat sondern auch der Fokus
und andere Herr Stegner sie sind ja
gerade den Koalitionspartner der Grünen
mit der SPD muss ja stolz da eingreifen
muss aufgeräumt werden oder ist es schon
in Ordnung also ich habe die
Personalentscheidung nicht getroffen das
muss jeder selber wissen wie er das
macht klar Mentalität ist es ein
bisschen würde ich sagen schrill Clans
sind machen illegale Dinge ganz machen
illegale Dinge auf das kann ich hier
nicht erkennen und man muss wenn man
fair ist auch sagen also es ist nicht
richtig ist alle Stellen ausgeschrieben
werden müssen es gibt sehr wohl stellen
auch im engeren Bereich die nicht
ausgeschrieben werden müssen und es ist
natürlich auch keineswegs so wenn ich
die Beschreibung hier sehe wer da mit
dem lobbymäßig verbunden ist dass das
jetzt was man singulär dem Kollegen
Robert habe zu schreiben könnte wenn ich
mir das im Gesundheitsbereich angucken
im Bereich der Rüstungsindustrie im
Bereich von
Automobilindustrie in Verbindung in
Regierung die CSU hat in Bayern meine
ganze Weile haben die Familien Leute
beschäftigt oder das richtig illegal
gewesen
genauso falsch ohne Konsequenz
bei den wo es illegal war da nicht nur
falsch sondern auch illegal hier reden
wir nicht weil Illegalität weiß ja auch
jeder trotzdem muss es jeder wissen ich
muss das nicht verteidigen
Personalentscheidung nicht getroffen
aber ich habe es nicht den ein oder sie
Politik des Hauses geprägt ist durch die
Familienstruktur von robertal weil
Schleswig-Holstein also das ist nicht
mein Eindruck aber das ist kann man
kritisieren und wie gesagt muss jeder
selbst rechtfertigen welcher
Entscheidung recht wichtig scheint mir
aber schon zu sein das Rechnung Gesetz
beachtet wird ob man dann darüber hinaus
sagt findet man nicht gut ist eine
andere Frage das unterscheidet das von
der CSU Geschichte muss ich schon sagen
und Clans das kann man glaube ich nicht
so in den Clans zeichnen sich sondern
dadurch aus dass dann man schon mal das
Gesetz ein bisschen gebogen wenn man
macht sich das so eigen das würde ich
jetzt den Weg gehen mein ganz ganz ganz
ganz großes Problem dabei ist diese
Stellen werden ja von Steuergelder
bezahlt und ich möchte schon dass mit
meinem Steuergeld die besten da sitzen
und nicht verschwiegerte Staat
Charaktere da muss ich sagen habe ich
schon Alarmsignal bei mir an das
anscheinend wirklich dann der Schwager
der beste auf Staatssekretär ist und der
andere Mann auch wenn man ihn jetzt
gerade zugehört hat war das eigentlich
als Bürgerin wie für mich wie ein
Plädoyer schon okay machen ja alle nee
nee nee Entschuldigung
nicht getroffen und ob man den
anscheinend vermeidet oder nicht muss
jeder für sich selbst wissen nur ich
finde es macht trotzdem noch einen
Unterschied gibt sind zwei verschiedene
Dinge eine ist Rechnung Gesetz das muss
eingehalten werden unterschiedliche
Leute das zweite ist dass man ob man
sich das damit Gefallen tut das so zu
machen darüber kann man streiten dass
das übrigens Leute die ihre Arbeit
können davon gehe ich schon aus weil
stellen die auch bezahlt sind und eine
Steuergeld das ist völlig in Ordnung da
gebe es übrigens viele Ansatzpunkte wo
man kritisch hingucken könnte ob mit dem
Steuergeld an der einen oder anständig
richtigen Leute auf die richtigen
Positionen kommen also ich wollte es mir
noch nicht parteipolitisch zeigen machen
sondern das ist jetzt der typisch und
hat mit dem Klima schützen sowas was du
und das glaube ich nicht aber wieso muss
jeder selber entscheiden die
Koalitionspartner entscheiden übrigens
über ihr Personal selbst insofern werden
einfach mein Forscher fahren Sie deshalb
oder jemand von den Grünen wir das
nächste Mal hier ist ich rede gerne über
die SPD da ist glaube ich eine Regierung
nicht mehr miteinander fahren aber es
geht natürlich nicht um diesen einen
Punkt von ihnen nochmal aufzukaufen es
geht natürlich nicht finde ich dass ein
Think Tank der sich außerhalb der
Regierung befindet aber Zuschüsse
bekommt von der Regierung dass über
diese Zuschüsse dann jemand entscheidet
der familiäre oder enge
verwandtschaftliche verbindnisse
Verbindungen hat zudem also es geht
nicht also praktisch in der familiär
oder innerhalb eines
Vertrauensverhältnisses entscheidet über
die Vergabe von Staats-
oder eine NGO an deren Spitze jemand
steht der mir persönlich sehr sehr nah
ist oder mit dem ich sogar verwandt bin
ich finde das hat schon ein Geschmäcker
oder mehr als ein geschmeckte hätten in
dem Fall schon sagen können müssen
irgendwie andere Entscheidungswege
gefunden werden weil man hatte fast ein
alter würde dann vielleicht am
Küchentisch über irgendwelche
Subventionen entschieden
Herr von Storch hätten sie überhaupt
eine Chance gehabt also Wissenschaftler
sie haben eine etwas andere Meinung als
die von Herrn Harbeck
ob ich was geschafft ja ob sie ob sie
glauben dass auch wirklich im
Wirtschaftsministerium braucht man auch
verschiedene Ansichten zu verschiedenen
Themen im Wirtschafts- und
klimaministerium da sind durch meine
Frage an Sie ob dadurch dass es da auch
dann keine Ausschreibung gab bei den
Fans vielleicht auch gar nicht genug
verschiedene Meinungen aufeinander
treffen
kennen die ja nicht irgendwie aber ich
habe den Eindruck dass das alles die
gleiche Blase ist dass sie sagen alles
das Gleiche sind verbunden über die
gleichen Denkschulen und ich könnte mir
eigentlich nicht denken das ist eine
gute politische Beratung sein kann wenn
das so uniform ist also ich denke der
hat aber habe ich mir besser damit
bedient wenn du da eine gewisse Breite
hätte an Meinungen dass die sich nicht
immer eine vielleicht sind sie sicher
vielleicht hassen die sich aber
jedenfalls es wäre besser wenn der mehr
Freiheitsgrade werden in diesem
Beratungsprozess und das finde ich dann
schon ein bisschen schade er vergibt
sich da möchte
dadurch dass er das so einschränkt das
nicht schon auch Dimensionen vergleichen
ist noch nicht allzu lange Regierung und
Leute ihre Verwandtschaftsbeziehung
genutzt haben um für den Ankauf von
Masken z.B zu werden schadhaftermaßen
über uns und damit nebenbei noch mal
richtig ordentlich Geld verdient haben
sie solche Beispiele irgendwo Leute sich
in der corona-krise wo die Menschen ja
ihre liebe Not hatten auch noch eine
Euro damit verdient haben deswegen
Minister kennen auch schreiben
veröffentlicht worden so nach dem Motto
sehr geehrter Herr Minister lieber so
noch kannst du nicht kennen deine Firma
die macht das ganz gut und dann bricht
sozusagen also insofern da ist der
direkte Beweis angetreten dass man davon
profitiert ist es immer gut den
anscheinend auch zu vermeiden das will
ich nicht bestreiten aber ich will schon
sagen man muss es immer ein und andere
war gerade in der letzten Legislatur
über folgenlos wenn ich das mal sagen
alles komplett folgenlos und da muss man
finde ich dann schon fair sein und nicht
sagen weil wir die Politik jetzt nicht
so sehr wir haben hier einen
koalitionskämpfer mit Herr Stegner er
verteidigt es gibt immer noch Fälle die
noch schlimmer sind das habe ich heute
schon gelernt ja also ich finde
eigentlich nicht zumuten dass wir ihn
mit der CSU vergleichen
Sie ihn einfach rein vielleicht kommt er
ja und dann aber
dass ich meine dass er sich das etwas
verliert
dadurch dass es sozusagen eine uniforme
beratungsumgebung hat die alle aus dem
gleichen Stall kommen dann wird
natürlich auch werden gar keine
richtigen Fragen mehr gestellt sondern
die werden sozusagen unter einem
gemeinsamen Ziel alle nur formuliert und
ich denke die Politik wäre besser
beraten wenn man tatsächlich versteht
das ist der verschiedene Ansätze geben
kann und ich glaube der verliert er eine
Chance ich werde aber selbst nicht tun
also um das klar
schade und ich finde es ist keine gute
Politik Beratung die er da betreibt und
das finde ich aber sagen dass das nun
außerdem vielleicht ein schlechtes ist
eine andere Geschichte und dass die CSU
ist noch viel wilder macht okay
sie merken schon es scheint ganz also
fast ja schon normal zu sein gar keine
Hysterien am Tisch das ist fast schon
anerkannt sowas aber wie ist es denn im
sozialen Bereich also ich weiß nicht ob
das normal sein kann ich finde auch
Beispiele zu holen die Partei macht das
so die Partei hat auch die Fehler
gemacht ich denke Politik hat
Verantwortung
muss glaubwürdig in der Öffentlichkeit
wirken und muss bestimmte Dinge einfach
aushebeln ich kann mir auch bestimmte
Sachen nicht erlauben ich meine ich
stehe auch im Rampenlicht und auch als
Sozialträger muss ja aufpassen dass ich
die Dinge richtig mache natürlich ich
finde es auch gut wenn meine Mitarbeiter
und Ihr Ehepartner in der gleichen Sache
arbeiten weil ich das Gefühl habe dann
sind sie sozialkompetent aber ich möchte
schon dass meine Mitarbeiter dann auch
die besten sind und dann müssen sie das
auch beweisen das hat was mit
Glaubwürdigkeit zu tun es gibt sondern
ganz altes biblisches Wort das heißt an
den Früchten werden sie erkannt und wenn
man die Früchte nicht erkennt bei den
Leuten die dann in diese Vätern
Wirtschaft geholt werden ich will es gar
nicht klaren Wirtschaft nehmen in der
Politik muss ich besonders aufpassen
gerade in Zeitalter wo alle gerade in
einem
triele ist relativ schwierig haben zu
regieren und sich sowieso nicht einig
sind hat man das Gefühl dann muss man
sehen wie sieht der Bürger das und wenn
der Bürger diese Schlagzeilen liest und
wenn der Bürger das sieht dann wird er
der Politik noch mehr verdrossen und da
haben wir gerade ein großes Problem mit
dass Menschen weniger zur Wahl gehen das
haben wir bei der letzten Wahl gesehen
dass Menschen sagen okay Politik
deswegen kann ich nicht mehr abnehmen
das hat ganz viel mit Glaubwürdigkeit zu
tun ist im sozialen Bereich genau das
gleiche auch als Pastor wir als Kirchen
haben auch das Problem wir sind auch
nicht mehr so glaubwürdig wie wir es mal
waren aber wir müssen auch an unseren
Früchten erkannt werden wir müssen auch
versuchen das Richtige zu tun und das
ist die verdammte Pflicht der Politik
meiner Meinung nach egal welche Partei
was zu sagen hat da hat die CDU ihre
Fehler gemacht da haben die Grünen ihre
Fehler gemacht dann lernen wir doch mal
aus den Fehlern und versuchen es besser
zu machen völlig davor ich habe nur Wert
darauf gelegt ich finde es immer noch
schwieriger wenn man rechengesetz
verletzt und ich bin sicher Sie haben
damals eine Sendung gemacht haben das
über die CSU da attackiert dafür also
dass das nur darum ging es mir ich würde
selbst nicht tun ich finde sie haben
Recht man sollte anscheinend gar nicht
mehr wecken am besten ist das so dass
überhaupt nicht meine anscheinend von
dem Vermutung entstehen kann aber wie
gesagt das müssen die Leute selbst
entscheiden und da die vereidigt werden
übrigens als Bundesminister entscheiden
können oder nicht das weiß ich nicht da
müssen auch Gremien sein die sozusagen
aufpassen sagen so bestimmte Dinge gehen
mit Compliance und so weiter schon ein
bisschen gucken
als allerletzte Frage die Antwort sind
sie mir noch schuldig geblieben wird
Herr Scholz reagieren oder wird der
Kanzler das dem herrweg alleine
überlassen was glauben Sie also nochmal
die Personalentscheidung treffen die
konditionspartner selbst
wäre das Gegenrecht und Gesetz wie in
den Fällen die ich genannt habe hätte da
kannst du sicher schon eingegriffen das
ist offen konnte nicht das ist auch
nicht geheim das muss man nicht gut
finden muss ich einmal muss das nicht
verteidigen können nicht von den Gründen
Minister
in der Politik das ist nicht schön da
kann man aber immer nur sozusagen an
sich selber gehen ich würde das so nicht
machen aber jetzt gehen wir weg von der
Politikverdrossenheit die wir jetzt
schon am Tisch Streit gemerkt haben hin
zur Klima letzte Generation
Verdrossenheit und da ist ja hier der
absolute Experte Alexander Kistler auf
jeden Fall wenn sie mal sehen Ballon
gebracht ja ich muss gestehen ich habe
nicht diese Gelassenheit bei diesem
Thema die ich sonst gerne hätte bei
vielen Dingen man will sich ja nicht
jeden Tag aufregen aber gestern habe ich
wieder mal sehr sehr aufgeregt in Berlin
konnten 17 Rettungswagen nicht an ihr
Ziel kommen weil klimakleber den Weg
blockiert haben weil sich auf Straßen
festgeklebt haben zeitweilig waren von
125 feuerwehrwägen sagt die Feuerwehr
nur 15 Uhr überhaupt einsatzfähig nein
das sind keine klimakleber wir haben es
hier nicht mit verstrahlten Jugendlichen
unters senilen Rentnern zu tun es geht
auch nicht um Demonstranten oder im
Aktivisten es sind Extremisten das
müssen wir leider Gottes genauso
benennen es sind Extremisten der
Klimaschutz ist vorgeschoben sie wollen
eine andere Gesellschaftsordnung haben
ihr Kampf richtet sich gegen die
Freiheiten im Kapitalismus gegen das
Gesellschaftssystem gegen eine
repräsentative Demokratie sie wollen
bürgergeräte einführen sie sagen die
Reichen wollen wir uns nicht mehr
leisten dann kann ich nur sagen es ist
vor allem der Sozialstaat der sich die
Reichen leisten muss weil die reichen
eben das größte aufkommt das
Sozialstaates erwirtschaften das sind
leider Gottes Extremisten daran muss man
festhalten und diese Erkenntnis ist noch
nicht bei allen polit politischen
Parteien bei allen Medien auch nicht in
allen Kirchen vorgedrungen nach wie vor
hat man ein leichtes Verständnis dafür
man sagt wir müssen die Verzweiflung
doch ernst nehmen das sagt ja nur das
hat beispielsweise auch die evangelische
ST Thomas Kirche in der nach wie vor
Pressekonferenzen und öffentliche
frühstücke mit diesen Verband mit dieser
letzten Generation stattfinden ich finde
nein ich habe kein Verständnis für diese
Methoden ich habe mittlerweile auch gar
kein Verständnis mehr für diese Anliegen
es geht den nicht um das Klimaschutz es
geht der letzten Generation um eine neue
semi-sozialistische Gesellschaft mit
weniger Freiheiten für alle sie wollen
ihre eigenen Krankheiten ihre eigene
Panik die sie auf die Gesellschaft
projizieren durchsetzen und uns zum
Handlungsmaxime auferlegen nein keine
Toleranz mehr Extremisten als
Extremisten benennen und Politik Kirchen
und Medien müssen endlich mit der
Verharmlosung
waren ja sehr lange angekündigt schon
hat er die Polizei versagt ja also
Polizei stellte ist natürlich auch ist
ein sehr schwieriges Pflaster es gibt
der Polizei erkennt er nicht im
luftleeren Raum werden jetzt den Fall
dass einige in Gewahrsam genommen wurden
die Waren dann schnell wieder frei da
die Justiz offenbar gesagt ach geht doch
wieder weg und heute haben wir schon
eine neue Eskalationsstufe das also
Polizei und Justiz öffentlich verhöhnt
werden von der letzten Generation weil
sie sagen heute in einer frischen
Presserklärung so langsam kommen sie an
die Ente ihre Kapazitäten Polizei in
Justiz mein freut sich also dass man es
geschafft hat so viel Arbeit
polizeiindustrie zu machen dass sie gar
nicht mehr hinterherkommen die Leute
sagt die nicht zu erfassen
gewarnmaßnahmen Maßnahmen auszusprechen
etc pp man will den Rechtsstaat
lahmlegen das ist das Ziel den
Rechtsstaat lahmlegen und während der
Rechtsstaat an Herzen liegt der muss
sagen Nein und deshalb würde ich mir
auch eine Polizei Wünschen nach einem
politische Leitung vielleicht macht
seine neue Schatz rote Regierung besser
hier in Berlin die genau hinschaut die
weniger die gesamthandschuhe und diese
anpackt und wenn es Journalisten
rausbekommen vorher mit rauszubekommen
wo diese Situation stattfinden könnten
auch proaktiv denke ich mir Polizisten
das herausbekommen und verhindern dass
diese Situation überhaupt erst entstehen
denn man spielt dort wirklich mit den
Menschenleben anderer unbeteiligter die
entweder im Krankenwagen sind oder
darauf warten dass die Feuerwehr
rechtzeitig zu Ihnen kommen das ist ein
Spiel mit dem Menschenleben ist ein
Zynismus nicht zu überbieten es stecken
erscheint ja fast ein wenig so als habe
die Regierung Verständnis mit den
klimaaktivisten nein das kann man glaube
ich so nicht sagen ich muss da fein
trennen ich finde es in der Tat das
recht junger Leute dass sie sich für die
Zukunft für den Klimaschutz einsetzen
dass die ungeduldig sind verstehe ich
auch ich habe als junger Mensch auch
gegen andere Dinge demonstriert
gegen zum Waffen und sowas habe das auch
alles getan und Protest darf auch nicht
so sein dass er nicht jeden gefällt der
darf auch unbequem sein die Grenze ist
für mich da
wo Gewalt ausgeübt wird Verrechnung
Gesetz verletzt wird wo in der Tat zum
Beispiel Rettungskräfte behindert werden
in ihrer aber da ist für mich eine
deutliche ganz viel auch den Namen
letzte Generation anmaßen und falsch mir
sind da die Fridays for future deutlich
sympathischer und ich habe da null
Sympathien wäre echt ein Gesetz
verletzten Gewalt ausübt der Muster
wahrscheinlich wieder bei schon auch
sagen man muss auch in der Beurteilung
soll man die Kirche im Dorf lassen wenn
ich höre dass er doofmann sagt dass er
eine Klima eröffnet muss ich sagen ja es
läuft es war eine Mörder waren die haben
Leute umgebracht und haben über viele
Jahre das Land ja das ist schon normal
eine andere Sache wenn ich hier Dinge
tun die nicht in Ordnung sind muss man
damit umgehen das tut unser Gesellschaft
glaube ich auch und ich halt auch nichts
davon das zu haben die Grenze wenn ihr
wollt dass euer an die ernst genommen
wird dann könnt ihr nicht Rettungswegen
blockieren oder Leute daran hindern dass
sie als Rettungskräfte ihre Arbeit tun
da ist die Grenze überschritten dagegen
muss auch vorgegangen werden meiner
Meinung nach aber dass die vielleicht
auch Wege Menschen die uns stören an
bestimmten Stellen ja mein Gott das ist
bei solchen das unterscheidende
freiheitlichen Demokratie übrigens von
anderen dass man das darf natürlich bin
ich ja sehr dafür es ist auch keine
Klima erreichst würde ich auch ablehnen
aber wir wissen nicht aus dem Blick in
die Geschichte RAF hat auch so ähnlich
begonnen das muss man ja auch sagen mit
ich sag mal verwöhnten bürgerkindern die
also ein Anliegen hatten die sich
sektenmäßig abgeschlossen haben sich
gegenseitig befeuert haben aus einem
teilweise popkulturellen teilweise
evangelisch theologischen Hintergrund
kam wie jetzt auch und sich immer mehr
radikalisiert haben weil sie meinten nur
so ihre Ziele durchsetzen zu können und
diese Binnenstruktur die sieht man
momentan auch bei der letzten Generation
ich bin dafür zuversichtlich dass daraus
keine Klima erreicht wird bin ich nach
wie vor aber wir bewegen uns an der
Einflug Schneise und die letzten Wochen
und Monate werden entscheiden ob wir
hier gemeinsam als Gesellschaft also
überzeugte Demokraten ein Stoppschild
errichten oder ob man durch Klamm
heimliches Einverständnis dafür sorgen
dass dieser Weg in den Terrorismus
beschritten wird der jetzt noch nicht
begonnen hat
Generation mit einer Sekte vergleichen
von der Art wie sie argumentiert ja
wirklich schon sagen es hat für mich
sektenhafte Züge weil man sich selbst
ermächtigt also wir haben gewissermaßen
die Weisheit mit Löffel gefressen wir
wissen ganz genau wie alles zu ticken
hat ihr seid alle zu dumm ihr habt das
alle nicht begriffen und weil es ebenso
furchtbar ernst ist immer mal Tee am
letzten bei denen greifen wir jetzt als
letzte wirklich also letzte auf heute
Apokalypse gewissermaßen zu den letzten
Mitteln und diese selbst Ermächtigung
diese zwei greifen zu radikalen Mitteln
der Anspruch für alle zu reden wir sind
die 99%. das ist ein Sekten denken man
schottet sich ab auch für Einwände von
außen die sagen liebe Leute schaltet mal
Eingang runter auch teilweise der Grünen
haben sich distriert nein man fährt
immer weiter man schaltet sogar noch
hoch man will noch mehr leben
manche sprechen ja auch mit Blick auf
die letzte Generation von etwas wie
glauben oder auch wie Kirche sie sind
Theologe hässliche Kur sehen Sie eine
religiöse Dimension Beispiel eine
radikale Dimension und zwar wenn man von
vornherein eine Straftat
begeht und die schon ankündigt dann muss
man das dagegen vorgehen und ich sehe
auch dass wenn man sagt ich bin der
einzige selig machende ich bin der
einzige der die Weisheit wir dürfen
gefressen hat dann stimmt irgendwas
nicht wenn ich selber
wieder von der Glaubwürdigkeit der
Politik wenn ich mit meinem Auto auf die
Autobahn fahre den Verkehr lahm lege
dann aussteigen mich auf die Straße
klebe dann frag ihn was ist dann da
Klima neutral dann fahre ich nicht mit
dem Auto nicht zu Fuß und ich glaube das
ist schon ganz schön Herausforderung was
man sagt natürlich versuchen die Leute
uns zu sagen dass sie die einzigen sind
die genau wissen wie es geht und immer
mehr verabschieden sich von ihm Fridays
for future hat gesagt wir wollen mit dir
nichts zu tun haben wir wollen gehen mit
denen nicht ein und ich denke man ein
bisschen aufpassen dass die Leute die
dort stehen und auch als Pressesprecher
auftreten und bestimmte Dinge sagen
wollen und sagen wollen warum sie das
machen eine Argument von einer
Pressesprecherin war zum Beispiel als im
adlonder diese Raketen abgeschossen
haben zu sagen ja wir wollen eine
Fußspur absetzen wir wollen den Reichen
deckenzettel verpassen weil die haben ja
schließlich die Konzerne was ist das für
eine Aussage die schaffen sozusagen
Arbeitsplätze da wird gearbeitet und
deswegen werden sie bestraft natürlich
Pulver an manche jetzt ihr Zeug durch
die Schornstein in den Himmel und da
muss man sicherlich was gegen machen
aber ich werde jetzt auch derjenige der
gegen Kinderarmut ist in diesem Land
werde mich nicht vor die Kaufhäuser
stellen und die ganzen Regale leer
plündern alles kaputt schlagen und sagen
so wIR müssen was gegen Kinderarmut
Unternehmen das muss man auf eine andere
Ebene machen da muss man vernünftig
diskutieren da muss man vernünftig
argumentieren und wir sprechen jetzt
viel von den Rettungskräften wir
sprechen nicht von der Polizei die
gebündelt wird dorthin zu gehen und die
Kleber von der Straße zu lösen das sind
die gleichen Polizisten die zu einer
Vergewaltigung kommen müssten das sind
die gleichen Polizisten die dahin kommen
müssen wo häusliche Gewalt ist und es
braucht immer mehr Polizei weil die
Menschen sozusagen dafür sorgen oder die
letzte Generation dafür sorgen dass da
immer mehr Menschen gebunden werden
Polizisten gebunden werden die
eigentlich andere Aufgaben haben was
kostet dem Steuerzahler Geld und dann
werden sie bestraft mit der Strafe von
1000 €, die Maßnahmen die dort
vorgenommen werden müssen um die von der
Straße zu holen sind viel teurer als
1000 warum gibt die evangelische Kirche
immer wieder ein Podium auch diesen
radikalen sogenannten Klimaschützer
lässt sie auf Kirchentagen aufregen oder
jetzt in der St Thomaskirche wird sowohl
eine Pressekonferenz gemacht wo diese
Aktion Straftaten auch angekündigt
werden findet öffentliches Frühstück
statt das heißt wir müssen eure
Verzweiflung ernst nehmen also ich finde
die Kirche vor allem die evangelische
Kirche macht sich dort zu sehr gemein
mit einer doch sehr sehr grenzwertigen
Bewegungen und sie stößt dadurch glaube
ich auch viele Leute ab die von der
Kirche sich andere sagen recht aber wir
müssen alles ernst nehmen aber wenn wir
merken dass es nicht richtig ist dann
müssen auch dafür irgendwas tun und da
richtig verteidigen Kirche nicht ganz im
Gegenteil da wird wahrscheinlich eine
Plattform geboten gehört sich einfach
nicht wir haben jetzt hier schon ganz
viele Begriffe auch gehört ja von Storch
zu der letzten Generation passt für sie
überhaupt der Begriff klimakleber oder
ist ja eine Verniedlichung
das war sie die kann man schon so nennen
aber ich würde zunächst mehr zustimmen
dass sie eigentlich andere Motive haben
die meinen gar nicht Klima oder
andersrum auch die haben eigentlich gar
nicht verstanden worin das Thema Problem
besteht nämlich das ist ein globales
Problem ist es geht darum wenn wir nur
von CO2 reden um 40 Milliarden Tonnen
die pro Jahr imitiert oder 35 bis 40
limitiert werden die müssen weg und wie
die Maßnahmen die die einfordern dazu
führen soll es vor schon unklar
die Reden eigentlich nur immer über Bibi
Fax und die die sozusagen positiv meinen
den Menschen in der Kirche würde ich mal
annehmen haben das auch nicht verstanden
die glauben auch wir in Deutschland
können das Problem so indem wir
verzichten lösen weil wir leben dann ja
vor wie schön das ist wenn man das so
macht da lachen natürlich die Menschen
in Indien sich kaputt darüber der dass
sie uns folgen sollen in dem von Konsum
Verzicht das heißt die wird
Herausforderungen für heute
sagen wollte
großartig also die was ist denn die
wirkliche Herausforderung
sonst vergessliche das ist sie dürfen
das gerne vortragen
also Lage und Optionen nenne ich das mal
zunächst mal der Klimawandel ist real
erst weitgehend Mensch gemacht und den
Maßen steuerbar durch die Emission von
Treibhaus
okay das Konzept der Kipppunkte auf die
man sich ja dass man sich ja hier immer
wieder bezieht ist akademisch attraktiv
schönes Thema kennt man dass der Physik
hier würde ich Musik aber findet durch
die Analyse der bestehenden Lage kaum
Unterstützung wenn Sie den IPCC Bericht
gucken
von Maxdome in Hamburg der genau in dem
Bereich mitgearbeitet hat die haben sich
mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt ist
nicht einfach so dass der nichts steht
weil sich nicht darum kümmert haben
sondern haben festgestellt das ist nicht
aktuell aber das Thema ist politisch
wirksam da könnte man aber auch mal
reden wieso eigentlich
werden Sie uns den deutschen Beitrag zum
Klimawandel Ansehen des gegenwärtig
gering in der Summe nicht pro Kopf aber
für den Klimawandel geht es nur um die
Summe nicht um Gerechtigkeit wer das
co2-molekül rauslässt an Bäcker aus
Berlin oder jemand in Vietnam ist egal
für das Thema
dann der Klimawandel kann nicht gänzlich
vermieden werden ist der teilweise auch
schon da und an Endpunkt des Anstieg ist
der globalen Mitteltemperatur wenn wir
das mal als Proxy nehmen als Indikator
für den Klimawandel von 1,5 oder 2 Grad
wie ein gigantischer Erfolg aber
immerhin sind ja zwei Grad dann schon im
Sack
das wirtschaftliche System das hinter
den weltweiten Emissionen steht
industrieverkehr Energie-
der wichtige Punkt ist da die
Treibhausgasemissionen in ihrer Summe
wirken es ist die Summe und nur die ist
für das Thema interessant
kann eine merkbare Steuerung des
globalen Mensch gemachten Klebeband
wandelst nur gelingen wenn die großen
Emittenten
teilnehmen also China Indien USA EU
können darüber verhandeln wieder alles
mitnehmen
innovative aber isolierte Maßnahmen die
in Deutschland zu Emissionsminderung
implementiert werden bleiben weitgehend
wirkungslos zu werden diese nicht schon
Nachahmung durch andere Akteure führen
also wenn andere Leute ist der Nachbarn
die sagen ja toll macht gut aber wie
kann man das hinkriegen diese Nachahmung
ich meine nur durch ökonomische Vorteile
was meinen Sie mit ökonomische Vorteile
es muss sich lohnen also ich muss ja ich
mein Leben muss irgendwie besser sein es
muss ein bisschen mehr so sein wie in
Hollywood Film
sie wollen die Klimakrise wie ein
Hollywood-Film die Menschen Indien in
China und sonstwo und Nigeria die wollen
ein besseres Leben haben und das kriegen
sie unter anderem vorgeführt von
Hollywood Filmen jetzt interessiert gar
nicht was die jungen Leute hier machen
entscheidend ist was die Menschen
draußen in der Welt machen da die eben
auch für den meisten Teil Emissionen
beantwortet sind dass wir eine ganze
Menge isoliert imitiert haben ist klar
und die einzig konsequente Antwort von
unserer Seite wäre die freigesetzten
Gase wieder reinzuholen dann würden wir
natürlich unsere Schuld abarbeiten aber
keiner Flensburg
als wir da das CO2 in den Boden sollte
also wie können wir ökonomische Kinder
also darum dass die ökonomische Vorteile
initiiert werden und nicht moralische
oder politische Ansprüche also sie
wollen das ökonomische Vorteile für
Nigeria Indien China und andere Länder
möchten die Menschen dort dass sie sagen
ja das lohnt sich für mich und zwar so
wie sie es meinen nicht so wie ein
Mensch in ich glaube das Kreuz hier in
Deutschland wie sehen sie wie schätzen
Sie das ein und übertreiben wir in
Deutschland gibt es eine Historie oder
ja Sie dürfen noch sagen ja gerne
also technologische Innovationen ja
scheint mir die einzige realistische
Perspektive eine ökonomischen motivierte
Nachahmung Bekannten aus was zu
erreichen also zum Beispiel dass die
Menschen in China sagen ja ich will ein
Auto haben und ich bin bereit ein
Elektroauto zu fahren
Maße deshalb weil es einfach billiger
ist
weil das ganz ganz viele Punkte sind
sehr gute referieren aber sind so viele
verschiedene Punkte Elektroautos
beispielsweise sind ja auch nicht ohne
jegliche Kritik oder das kann man gut
eine Kritik daran leisten und da würde
ich auch vorstellen dass wir natürlich
sehr schön wenn es uns gelingen würde
unser wesentlichen Ressorts in diesem
Land nämlich technisches Wissen dafür zu
sorgen dass die Umweltbelastung durch
die Entwicklung und Elektroautos
geringer wird
so das sind also die Hauptpunkte das
nochmal zusammen oder was also der
Mensch gemachte Klimawandel ist eine
reale Herausforderung muss politisch
verhandelt werden
sowohl im Hinblick auf die Minderung der
Missionen als auch auf die unvermeidbare
Anpassung das heißt der einzige der hier
in der Runde habe ich den Eindruck was
ordentlich dazu also qualifiziert ist
sozusagen verstehe
gleich mal den den besonders
nicht dabei ist die entscheidende Frage
die eben zum Beispiel für Futures und
von Generation nicht gestellt wird die
nach der Wirksamkeit von Maßnahmen
sowohl bei der Anpassung als auch beim
bei der Behinderung der Mission die
Wissenschaft kann helfen festzustellen
welche Maßnahmen wie wirksam sind wenn
ich dies tue kriege ich jenes also wenn
wir mal einen Corona Beispiel nehmen
würden wir können eben sagen wenn wir
die Kontakte unter den Menschen
einschränken dann können wir die
Verbreitung des Virus und so
einschränken aber diese arme Virologe
kann ich sagen welche Folgen das hat für
die Kinder die nicht mehr zur Schule
gehen und aber es gehört zum Problem
dazu
Wissenschaft alleine
breiter denken verschiedene Experten mit
reinholen und wissenschaftlich Disziplin
welche Maßnahmen politisch zu wählen
sind das ist eine politische
Entscheidung und die gesellschaftliche
Willensbildung berücksichtigt die
wissenschaftliche Einschätzung also das
Zeugung wenn wir sagen würde das
funktioniert nicht alle in der Nase
wurden singt daraufhin nicht der CO2
Gehalt aber sie entscheidet nach
politische Abwägung Logik und das dafür
haben wir ja Politik diesen Prozess der
eine ein Ausgleich von
gesellschaftlichen Interessen wollen wir
einmal die Debatte eröffnen weil ich
glaube wir können uns gar nicht alle
Punkte am Tisch nach dann da merken und
Herr Stegner wurde ja schon gebeten zu
antworten ich habe nur gesagt er hat er
ist viel mehr im Zentrum des Interesses
in der Zentrum des Tools als irgendein
harmloser
ich stimme Ihnen durchaus in manchen zu
was Sie gesagt haben zum einen muss man
sagen wir haben ein Problem mit dem
Menschen gemacht und Klimawandel das
kann man auch nicht bestreiten das sagen
einem die Wissenschaftler wir müssen da
was tun unsere Kinder und Engel haben
das gleiche Recht wie wir selbst in
Wohlstand und Frieden zu leben meine
Generation ist die erste die das tun
dürfen wir unser Aufgabe ist dafür zu
sorgen dass das so bleibt nun heißt das
nicht und wir haben viele Fehler in der
Vergangenheit gemacht du hast das nicht
wir können jetzt zum Beispiel Chinesen
oder erinnern oder sagen verzichte dir
mal bitte auf Wachstum weil das ist für
die Welt geht nicht ja was ich immer
China als Beispiel wir haben eine große
Industriegesellschaft in Deutschland
wenn wir weltweit wenn wir in der Lage
wären unsere Industrie die übrigens sehr
viel höheren Energiebedarf hat
als das im privaten Bereich gilt so
umzubauen dass die klimaneutral wird
wenn wir zeigen wie das geht technisch
zeigen wie das geht und es auf eine
Weise machen die sozialverträglich
anders geht es in Demokratie nämlich
nicht dann würde das die Chinesen
deutlich eher überzeugen wie was der
Vergangenheit über uns wissen als wenn
wir in moralische Vorträge halten so ist
das übrigens im Inneren genauso ich
finde diese moralische Stellen Alarm
also sind ja nicht immer ja ich muss ihn
ehrlich sagen ich will was Positives
sagen kann man nicht immer sagen über
die deutsche Wirtschaft wenn sie mit
großen Konzern Chefs heute reden die
nicht mehr über die Frage ob sie das
machen wollen sondern wie die Regierung
verhandelt außer sie mit ihnen über
Rahmenbedingungen wie man das hinkriegen
kann die meisten haben das sehr wohl
begriffen die wissen dass sie keine
Autos mehr verkaufen können die die Luft
verpesten dass ich das ändern muss die
wissen dass wir technologische
unterschiedliche Wege gehen müssen wenn
ich völlig verdrottelt ist weiß das und
deswegen sage ich mal es ist eine
Aufgabe wo das Management natürlich oder
werden den weltweit
keine Autos das ist natürlich das
alleine überzeugt mich jetzt nicht
natürlich kann Deutschland das nicht
lösen aber Deutschland ein großes
Industrieland wir sind Technologie mäßig
so gut haben Ingenieure haben
Wissenschaft dass wir in der Lage sein
müssten in manchen Bereichen auch
Weltmarktführer zu werden das dann auch
hier zu produzieren nebenbei unser
Anteil ist wie hoch der deutsche Anteil
CO2
ja das weiß ich das aber alleine ist
doch keine Antwort das geht ja in jedem
Bereich wenn sie sagen ach das lohnt
sich gar nicht dass ich mich irgendwie
ändern weil es macht mir ohnehin nicht
genug das kann sein Demokratie nicht
sein da darf nur nicht Illusion haben
dass das reicht ich sag trotzdem noch
mal wenn ein Land wie Deutschland größte
Land in Europa riesenindustrieland mit
all den Möglichkeiten die wir haben
zeigt wie das geht technisch und nicht
anderen Vorträge hält ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das umgesetzt
wird und das ist weltweit gute
Entwicklungen deutlich höher und ich
halte überhaupt nichts davon überzeugt
zu reden den Leuten irgendwas zu
predigen moralpredigen sein er taucht
uns auch nach außenwürdiglich nichts
sondern in der realen Welt anzusetzen
sich mit den realen gegeben zu
beschäftigen und das zu tun was wir tun
können da sind wir deutlich unter
unseren Möglichkeiten an mancher Stelle
und oder Scholz hat zu Recht gesagt
natürlich
die größte industrielle Aufgabe die wir
in den letzten 100 Jahren hatten und das
müssen wir erstmal hinkriegen und das
ist eine gewaltige Aufgabe die kann man
nicht so eben Schultern und wir haben
natürlich durch den Ukraine Krieg auch
Rückschritte wir haben Kohlekraftwerke
wieder ins Netz gebracht worden und
vieles ich finde es übrigens
Politiker ihren Chef loben dürfen
ja vielleicht darf ja auch ein
Journalist dann doch was ja ich bin
natürlich kein Klima
klimafutze und habe auch keinen direkt
im Bundestag aber ich sage meine Steuern
hier ich finde es immer erfrischend wenn
man hört wir müssen überzeugen durch
Technik durch Leiste unnötig Moral also
dieses Appell zum realistischen finde
ich sehr erfrischend und wird auch in
ihrer Partei und bei dem grünen schon
gar nicht nicht immer beherzigt dann
haben wir allerdings durch den blinden
Fleck und den kann ich natürlich uns ist
nicht ganz ersparen der Kernkraft ich
bin jetzt gerade in Finnland gewesen und
da war die interessante koezidenz das am
selben Wochenende an dem Deutschland aus
der Kernkraft für immer oder
vorübergehend wer weiß es schon
ausgestiegen ist wurde dort ein
Kernkraftwerk eröffnet und da hat er
zuständige Minister glaube ich gesagt
das ist zentraler Bestandteil unserer
grünen Klimawende der Eröffnung dieses
Kernkraft und auch hammer groß sieht das
so und auch Herr trudo hat jetzt sein
Scholz ein Kanada einen kleinen Vortrag
gehalten warum man eigentlich für die
Klimawende Kernkraftwerke bräuchte also
ich glaube überzeugen durch Leistung und
Realismus bin ich ganz bei Ihnen aber
man könnte auch durch die realistische
Einschätzung und durch die Leistung
deutscher kernwerkstechnologie
überzeugen und dass man sich ich möchte
mal wirklich sagen ohne Not einer so
schwierigen Situation jetzt um eben
die Grünen diesen Fetisch des Kernkraft
Ausstieges zu geben sich von dieser
Technologie verabschiedet dafür habe ich
haben viele andere sogar die Mehrheit
der Deutschen kein Verständnis da darf
ich Ihnen widersprechen
selbstverständlich weil die Atomkraft
ist die teuerste Energie von die wir
jemals hatten das muss ich Jahrtausende
bewacht werden der radioaktive Müll das
geht für keine andere Energieform wir
haben in Harrisburg wir haben in China
gesehen wir haben in Fukushima gesehen
was passiert bei der Techniker Mensch
nicht beherrschen war keine Fehler
machen und das schlimmere kommt noch
dazu es blockiert auch noch die
erneuerbaren Energien von denen wir
dringend mehr brauchen die französischen
im letzten Jahr fast die Hälfte still
weil die Flüsse nicht mehr hier ständig
gefüllt worden
ich kann nur sagen zehn Jahre länger
gedauert deswegen
wahnsinnig teuer
sie und ich eine für eine gefährliche
Technik das ist nicht die Lösungen
von vorgestern
gemacht haben dass sie ich gesagt haben
wir haben die Möglichkeiten zu zeigen
wie man klimaneutral zum Beispiel Dinge
macht das heißt sind meinen Worten wir
das schon eigentlich interessiert es gar
nicht so sehr wie viel wir die
Emissionen in Deutschland mindern weil
es mich zu wenig sind sondern dass wir
demonstrieren wie man das machen kann
und das muss man sich vorführen und bei
der Gelegenheit mindern wir auch unsere
Mission aber das wichtigste ist
tatsächlich nicht die Vision selbst
sondern das Entwickeln von Methoden
diese überall auf der Welt zu mindern
und dass man danach den Trichter kommen
könnte wir haben ja doch erhebliche
Fortschritte gemacht bei nicht wir also
die Ingenieure haben
schon gemacht bei der Kerntechnik das
ist ja nicht so dass wir immer noch die
kern-technischen Anlagen haben gegen
seinerzeit wahrscheinlich demonstriert
haben inzwischen gibt's ja neue und
möglicherweise sind die doch wirklich
wesentlich mehr geeignet und von
Jahrhunderttausenden ist da gar nicht
mehr die Rede sondern von deutlich
weniger Sachen ob das denn stimmt sei
mal dahingestellt aber immerhin wir
könnten darin unser Gehirnschmalz
reinstecken und das ist eigentlich die
Aufgabe wir sollen unser Gehirnschmalz
reinstecken zu zeigen wie kann man es
machen so dass es sich lohnt im Sinne
von Lebensqualität von den Menschen die
betroffen sind und nicht von denen in
Kreuzberg ihnen gehört das Schlusswort
weil es war ihre These und wir gehen
eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung und sind
dann wieder mit zwei weiteren spannenden
Thesen zurück
[Musik]
wir haben viel zu besprechen heute Abend
wie steht's in unser Land
damit herzlich willkommen bei Viertel
nach achtjährigen frei
und war doch allen klar ist wirklich zu
einfach Putin hat diesen Krieg begonnen
aber wir entscheiden doch was wir machen
eigentlich fordern sie die Aufarbeitung
und den Rücktritt von Karl Lauterbach
lieber umgekehrt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen als freiheitsliebender Mensch
würde ich sagen das muss jedem erlaubt
sein kein Maschen zwischen Bremer und
Bruder
wenn der Staat Geld verschenkt muss er
sehr irgendwo anders herbekommen das
wird das Problem nicht ändern das ist
unser mittelbar glaube ich auch kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass das so
durchgeht und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den wir reden sollten
damit der Film nach acht Entzug nicht zu
groß wird definitiv noch einmal
einschalten
[Musik]
wir sind zurück bei 8:15 Uhr
Lebensmittelpreise steigen überall und
die Lage ist dramatisch
seit april 2021 steigen die
Lebensmittelpreise bis heute ins
Unermessliche wir haben immer mehr
Menschen die sich teilweise gesunde
Nahrungsmittel gar nicht mehr leisten
können und unser Landwirtschaftsminister
fordert das gerade bedürftige Menschen
sollen sich gesund ernähren sie haben
nicht mehr das Geld um sich ungesund zu
ernähren
ich fordere eine Preisbremse für
Grundnahrungsmittel weil es kann nicht
sein dass ein halbes Brot 3,50 € kostet
das drei Paprika 399 Kosten und das
bedürftige Menschen das Nachsehen haben
immer mehr Familien haben Probleme sich
Lebensmittel zu leisten die Tafeln sind
überfüllt an manchen Orten nehmen die
Tafeln gar keine neuen Menschen in
unserer Einrichtungen in Berlin
Hellersdorf verteilen wir einmal im
Monat Lebensmittelpakete für vierköpfige
Familien an tausend Familien das ist
unbezahlbar 50.000 € die alleine durch
Spenden aufgebracht werden müssen wir
brauchen dringend eine Maßnahme und auch
Politik muss jetzt reagieren weil Kinder
sind immer bedürftige Kinder sind die
die am Ende des Tages die Leidtragenden
sind die haben Schulen die uns anfragen
ob wir ein kostenloses Frühstück zu
Verfügung stellen ich glaube wir sollten
darüber reden dass wenn wir die
Lebensmittelpreise so lassen wie sie
sind und unsere Kinder nicht besser
unterstützen dann ist das Unterlassen
Hilfe Leistung
was halten Sie von der Preisbremse ich
halte vor allen Dingen was von der
Förderung dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Kinder gesunde Nahrungsmittel bekommen
möglichst in der Schule übrigens auch
dass das ich bin dafür kostenfrei ist
essen wir werden Ganztagsschulen
nachhaltig Menschen Lebensmittel leisten
können müssen das darf nicht sein das
ist eine armutspunkt Kinderarmut finde
ich ganz furchtbar ich bin von den
Kindern Grundsicherung das müssen wir
alles tun ob die Preisbremse das
richtige Instrument ist nämlich nicht
ganz sicher aus zwei Gründen der eine
Grund ist unsere Landwirte wenn die
Milch verkaufen also sozusagen kriegen
teilweise dafür so wenig geboten dass
sie das dass sie davon selber nicht
leben können wer wie ich für Mindestlohn
ist der will auch das Landwirte
Lebensmittel ordentlich bezahlt werden
der Punkt ist das darf nur nicht da muss
führen das heißt diejenigen die
Lebensmittelpreise mögen insgesamt gar
nicht so hoch sein im Vergleich zu
anderen sind sie auch gar nicht so hoch
manchmal wird auch viel Lebensmittel
werden weggeschmissen weil sie so billig
sind aber in der letzten Zeit ist sind
die Preise angestiegen durch Inflation
und dafür muss seinen Ausgleich geben
für die mit den geringsten Einkommen da
haben sie völlig Recht und wie man das
macht und das ist die Verpflichtung des
Staates auch dafür zu sorgen dass das
geschieht wie man das macht da kann man
über die Methoden reden ich glaube eine
Preisbremse allein ist noch nicht der
ideale Weg aber jedenfalls dafür naja
der Punkt ist natürlich der die
Preisbremse wenn ich die mache dann
zahlen auch die Leute weniger die das
gut leisten können der Punkt ist ja
eigentlich eher der dass ich nicht
möchte dass das ein Armut Punkt das ist
aber so und daran muss man etwas ändern
gegen Kinder haben muss man was machen
gegen Erwachsene Armut auch
Mindestlöhne mit denen wir angefangen
haben bessere soziale Grundsicherung mit
denen wir begonnen haben bezahlbares
Wohnen dagegen geht das gerne die
Energiepreise so wenn Sie mir einen
Preis Bremsen beschlossen ja also eine
Menge versuchte unternehmen um Menschen
zu unterstützen dass sie damit
zurechtkommen aber es reicht noch nicht
da bin ich bei ihm und dann muss man
darüber reden wie der wird Gesellschaft
leisten ich gebe Ihnen Recht in dem
Punkt wenn der Bauer tatsächlich das
Geld für seine Milch bekommt und nicht
die Konzerne zwischendrin geschaltet
auch noch genug verdient dann habe ich
kein Problem dass auch die Preise
steigen aber letztendlich sieht es doch
so aus dass auch heute sich gerade
Unternehmen gesund stoßen weil alles
teurer wird und wir vergessen in unsere
Gesellschaft natürlich auch ein
bestimmtes Klientel von Menschen wenn
wir mal Zurückgehen auf die Kinderarmut
dann haben wir seit 22 Jahren ein
kinderarmutsbericht der sagte vor 22
Jahren wir haben 1,2 Millionen Kindern
Armut heute haben wir 3,6 Millionen
Kinder hat sich also verdreifacht das
heißt wir vergessen unsere Kinder auf
der ganzen Linie und Sie haben recht
natürlich braucht es in den Schulen ein
kostenloses Frühstück damit Kinder sich
überhaupt konzentrieren können dann
rechnet man wieder auf und sagt wer soll
das bezahlen die beste universition die
wir haben ist in unsere Kinder weil sie
sind eben nicht Zukunft der Gesellschaft
sondern erstmal Gegenwart also heute
investieren damit ich auch was rausholen
kann wenn ich so sehen darf aber sie wir
merken heute das immer mehr Menschen auf
der Strecke bleiben gerade Familien
gerade alleine ziehende die das
Nachsehen haben es gibt gar nicht genug
Existenz sicher eine Arbeitsplätze für
alle zehnte Mütter wir sprechen über
eine Altersarmut in die alleinerziehende
Mütter geraten die wir gar nicht
bezahlen können aber da muss Politik
letztendlich auch überlegen und wir
müssen jetzt eine ergreifen
Kindergrundsicherung ist gut die vorder
ist seit zehn Jahren aber wir reden
darüber dass wir sie 2025 umsetzen sind
die Kinder nicht heute da wir haben
heute 2023 was passiert denn wenn morgen
ein Kind verhungert ja es geht ja auch
nicht nur um die Kindergrundsicherung
sondern vor allem es geht ja auch in die
Mittelschicht rein sind ja nicht nur die
Ärmsten betroffen nur mal eben drei
Zahlen beispielsweise Paprika ist
letzten 12 Monaten und 66 % gestiegen
Quark um 64% zwiebeln und Knoblauch und
ganze
57%, die Unternehmen die diese
Lohnerhöhungen gezahlt haben die würde
ich gerne mal sehen die gibt's nämlich
nicht deswegen ist er die Frage finde
ich hier an der Stelle was bedeutet es
denn für die Gesellschaft na ja wie
gesagt die Gesellschaft ist ja vielerlei
Belastungen ausgesetzt die eine ist die
Inflation dass die Preise für uns alle
teurer werden das werden wir alle die
wir einkaufen gehen das heißt wir müssen
alle in größeres Budgets zurücklegen für
Gegenstände täglichen Bedarf aber auch
für die Miete und das andere ist
natürlich auch die Frage neben diesen
gestiegenden Preisen wer ist
werden muss darunter leiden vor allem
also wer kommt bei Ihnen an und da muss
man vielleicht auch die die Frage
stellen wir haben momentan über über 3
Millionen sogar eine Schutz Suchende in
Deutschland also der Zuzug nimmt die
auch zu aus anderen Ländern Frau Feser
macht ja nicht so richtig viel dagegen
also ich kann die Frage nicht
beantworten aber vielleicht gehört ja zu
einem Gesamtbild der Lage auch dazu dass
wir auch immer mehr Menschen aus fremden
Ländern haben die sozusagen Kunden
werden bei der Tafel und die dort auch
zum Kollaps des Betriebs für könnten
frage ich mal vielleicht können sie
beantworten
Sozialstaat ist doch fast beim Kurt wenn
wir immer mehr Menschen ins Land lassen
und ihn sagen kommt in unser Land wir
brauchen euch jetzt Fachkräfte schauen
aber noch gar nicht danach ob sie
wirklich Fachkräfte sein können wir
haben keinen Wohnraum wir haben keine
Kitaplätze hole ich mir einen Arzt aus
Indien nach Deutschland der bringt acht
Kinder mit unter Umständen das ist gar
nicht böse gemeint aber die müssen auch
irgendwo untergebracht werden die
brauchen Schulplätze alleine in Berlin
fehlen 1000 Lehrer ähm wo sollen die
Kitaplätze her allein in Berlin ich will
gar nicht sagen wie viel Kitaplätze
fehlen ist es ins Unermessliche wir
sprechen über Wohnraum der bezahlbar ist
und der sozialen Neid wird immer größer
in der Schlange von den 1000 Familien
die dort stehen die bei uns um eine
lebensmitteltüte patenwerte sozialen
sozialen leid immer größer weil die
Familie die mit sieben Personen in der
70 Quadratmeter Wohnung wohnt die seit
Jahren auf eine Wohnung warten diese
bezahlen können die ihn vermittelt wird
die sie in der Regel gar nicht kriegen
die dann von einer geflüchteten Familien
übernommen wird was auch richtig ist
aggressiver und die ist hausgemacht weil
ich kann nicht sagen Leute kommt alle in
unser Land wir werden euch schon
versorgen wir haben die Infrastruktur
gar nicht mehr und dadurch nehmen unsere
Kinder Schaden es gehen jedes Jahr
50.000 Kinder von der Schule ohne
Schulschluss und wir fragen nach
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland anstatt in
unsere Kinder zu investieren irgendwas
nicht aber ich spreche sie mal als
Pastor an man ganz ehrlich also das dass
wir dafür aufpassen
es ist richtig ja aber wir könnten bei
weitem nicht mit unseren Menschen die
wir haben unseren Bedarf an
Arbeitskräfte wir müssen was ganz
anderes tun wir müssen dafür sagen dass
die Menschen die zu uns kommen über uns
viele kommen nicht wegen unserem
Sozialsystem sondern sie flüchten von
dem kriegen der Ukraine
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die die zu
uns kommen hier arbeiten dürfen das
haben die Konservativen bisher verändert
jetzt können die nämlich Arbeiten
bezahlen die Steuern brauchen keine
Sozialtransfers machen übrigens auch
keine Unfug wenn sie Männer der Monate
lang in Unterkünften nichts tun kommt da
nichts gescheites bei raus die Afghan
zum Beispiel die nicht zurück können die
sollten arbeiten das haben wir jetzt an
zu ändern dass die Arbeiten dürfen und
dann kann man sich das dann kann man die
kümmern die Gewalttäter sind zum
Beispiel hier werden Familie mit Kindern
abgeschoben weil die Polizei leichter an
sie ran kommt die völlig integriert sind
das völlig daneben stattdessen sollen
uns um die kümmern die uns wirklich
Probleme machen das Gewalttäter sind zum
Beispiel und diejenigen die sie
integrieren wollen die arbeiten wollen
die muss noch arbeiten lassen das sind
nicht nur Fachkräfte sind zum Teil auch
in ganz einfachen Berufen Menschen nicht
mehr haben beispielsweise funktioniert
doch eigentlich nicht wirklich in diesem
Moment der Punkt ist aber das Problem
liegt darin abgeschoben werden Christen
die an die man am leichtesten rankommt
das sind gut integrierte Menschen deren
Kinder hier in die Schule gehen die
werden abgeholt fragen Sie mal
Polizeibeamten wie schön die das finden
dass sie das tun müssen und wir müssen
da komplett die Politik ändern das tun
wir uns mit allen drei Parteien SPD grün
und FDP das war mit der Union nie
möglich und die Wirtschaft hat es immer
gefordert lasst die Leute arbeiten die
Zahlen steuern Sie wissen in den
integriert wir tun uns schwer
ausländische Nachweise an zu erkennen da
haben wir dann Ärzte die Arbeiten hier
als Pfleger weil sie nicht das sind die
Deutschen ziemlich hochmütig da können
wir von Ländern wie Kanada oder anderen
auch was lernen wie das geht und ja wir
müssen aufpassen dass es nicht sozialen
Sprengstoff gibt durch den Wettbewerb
davon profitieren nämlich nur
rechtsradikal in Deutschland das kann
man besichtigen in manchen Gebieten mehr
als einem lieb sein kann der Kern ist
aber dass jeder der sich hier anstrengt
der Rechnung gesetzt einhält dass sie
integrieren will der die Sprache lernt
der arbeiten will den können wir
dringend brauchen und das ist teilweise
auch immer verpflichtet deswegen habe
ich jetzt Pastor angesprochen gehört
auch das können sie gar nicht ich habe
gar kein Problem damit dass wir Schutz
suchen in unser Land lassen wir können
aber nicht die Menschen in unser Land
lassen und sie bei den ehrenamtlichen
abgeben und sagen jetzt kümmert euch da
habe ich und da machen wir einen großen
Fehler wir haben immer mehr zu tun als
Arche die Tafeln haben immer mehr zu tun
und wir machen ein hausgemachtes Problem
ich habe gar kein Problem dass wir
Menschen in unser Land lassen das sollen
wir auch unbedingt tun und wenn sie über
Fachkräfte sprechen gar keine Frage aber
wir lassen wahllos Menschen in unser
Land wir machen wir wir schauen gar
nicht mehr nach wir lassen sie rein und
Fragen nicht danach brauchst Du unser
Land oder brauchst
das Problem allein mit seinen die
Menschen ertrinken im Mittelmeer lösen
wir das von ihm sicherlich dass die
Spitze des Eisbergs die Sie gerade
beschreiben also wenn eine
Außenministerin sich hinstellt und sagt
kommt alle in unser Land wir heben die
dieser Pflicht auf was gibt es für ein
Signal in die Öffentlichkeit und was
macht das mit den Menschen in unserem
Land die sind
jetzt können sie aber zum anderen Thema
äußern eigenen stecken aber sie heute
mitgebracht das will ich sehr gerne
sagen ich möchte gerne über
Meinungsfreiheit reden man liest immer
wieder es geben in Deutschland keine
Meinungsfreiheit es gebe einen
rot-grünes meinungskartell man dürfen
gar nicht mehr seine Meinung sagen das
ist eigentlich ganz schrecklich das wird
oft geschrieben und mein Eindruck ist
ein ganz anderer wenn man Länder sucht
wo es keine Meinungsfreiheit geht da
muss man nach Peking nach Moskau nach
Teheran reisen oder nach minskinder kann
man sich bei uns darf jeder sagen was er
will in der Tat hat man aber keinen
Recht darauf dass er nicht widersprochen
wird wenn man seine Meinung sagt und man
muss sich dem auch stellen wenn ich die
Zeitung lese habe ich jetzt von Rot Grün
überhaupt nicht den anderen wenn ich
spd-freundliche Meinung lesen will muss
ich fast den vorwärts lesen das ist
unsere Parteizeitung ansonsten höre ich
immer nur ständig der Bundeskanzler seit
zögerlich was die Ukraine angeht und
verzagt die Bevölkerung die einen
anspricht sieht das ganz anders ein
Roman der sich ja auch mit diesem Haus
hier teilweise mit beschäftigt macht
deutlich dass da geworden wird für die
FDP es wird viel für schwarz grün
geworden das ist alles okay ich glaube
darüber nicht gehört zu denjenigen die
mit solchen Debatten immer Stellen
Meinungsfreiheit heißt auch dass man
bereit sein muss Argumente auszutauschen
daran mangelt es übrigens bei der
Kriegsfrage auch das ist ein guter böse
schwarz und weiß war und unwahr statt
dass man Argumente austauscht man wird
nicht für das kritisiert was man sagt
sondern für eine Karikatur davon aber
man muss sich dem stellen das ist kein
Ponyhof als Politiker muss man sich eben
erst recht Stellen ich habe das immer in
meinem Leben getan und habe nicht den
Eindruck dass man darunter leidet ich
glaube nur manchmal haben keine guten
Argumente und deswegen ist diese
Weinerlichkeit gerade bei den
Konservativen dass er alles so
schrecklich rot grün also ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich habe das Buch noch
nicht gelesen ich werde das tun aber
wenn das sozusagen das Flaggschiff der
konservativen ist die dann dann in die
Sprache und Inhalt so bescheiden
Auftritte
behauptet aber das Buch schon gelesen da
geht's gar nicht gut aber die
Berichterstattung sagen hat ja auch
deutlich gemacht
das schaffe ich nur mit zwei Promille
was ich dann Zitaten gelesen habe was
das Problem in Deutschland
Studien für Sie mitgebracht aber eine
erstickt mir die fand ich ganz spannend
und zwar gehen wir mal nur zu den ARD
Volontären die Studie ist aus 2020 da
würden 92% grün rot rot wählen das ist
für den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
der übrigens von öffentlichen Geldern
bezahlt wird von GEZ Gebühr ist es
natürlich schon erschreckend für viele
Menschen in diesem Land wenn sie lesen
das 92% der ARD Volontäre grün rot rot
werden würden von der Studie von 2020
würden sie nicht sagen da gibt's
vielleicht doch ein klein wenig beim RR
hin zu unserem ich weiß das nicht essen
was Leute wählen ist ja und wie solche
Umfragen sind schade und drauf und was
Leute wählen ist in Zeitlang ich weiß
nicht ob sie eine Umfrage schon mal in
Ihrem Hause gemacht haben wie viele
Leute da SPD wählen ich habe den
Eindruck dass ich da manchmal wenn ich
in Diskussion von bin relativ alleine
bin und man eins gegen drei argumentiert
ich noch mal ich klare darüber nicht
dass
er Produkte kaufen
naja gut aber ich sag mal also das ist
ja nun nicht so dass die permanent die
SPD gelobt wurde wenn ich all den
zdf-gruppe ärgere ich mir genauso auf
die wenn ich andere Dinge lese und sehe
also ist das nicht mein Eindruck ist
nicht dass die Leute unterjocht werden
und schon gleich gar nicht dass ich
wieder von beeindrucken lassen also wenn
sich davon beeindrucken ließen wenn das
angeblich so wäre dann könnte ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass es Parteien gibt
die schon seit Jahren absolute Mehr oder
alleine regieren wie in Bayern
kritischen Journalismus deswegen sie
sagen eigentlich heute hier ich bin
zufrieden mit der Presse in diesem Land
ich sag nur die Meinungsfreiheit können
in der Demokratie dazu man darf das nur
nicht damit verwechseln dass man Recht
bekommt und wenn ich keine guten
Argumente habe zum Beispiel dann muss
ich mich nicht beschweren und dann
gehört auch eine gewisse Leidenschaft
über uns dazu dass man das auch aushält
in Essenz auszuhalten wissen Sie was
mich ärgert ich will das nicht verdienen
aber was mich ärgert wenn man hier gibt
es wenn wir genug reden Putin Freunde
oder Kriegstreiber Putin Freunde das ist
nicht rechtsradikalen und vielleicht vor
Wagenknecht ich habe damit nichts am Hut
aber wenn man sich erlaubt mit Differenz
der Meinung zu haben ist man sofort da
und da wünschte ich mir ein bisschen
mehr Bereitschaft zur altmodische Dinge
wie Argumente verwenden Sie nicht die
Frage würde ich auch gerne an Herr
Künstler geben es gibt ja genügend
Studien die zeigen dass die gefühlte
Meinungsfreiheit in diesem Land immer
immer schlechter wird also unter 50% der
Deutschen haben nach wie vor das Gefühl
noch ihre Meinung sagen zu können mich
persönlich alarmiert das es muss ja ein
Grund dafür geben dass es immer immer
wieder weniger Menschen gibt ihre
Meinung sagen und sind sie nicht
eigentlich in einer sehr privilegierten
Stellung weil als Politiker haben sie
sich das ja auch ausgesucht ich würde
mich übrigens auch niemals hinstellen
und sagen ich darf meine Meinung nicht
sagen ich sagte jeden Tag aber
entschuldigen sie mal darf ich immer
sagen wenn die Zeitung auch solche mit
ganz großen Buchstaben den Leuten
ständig sein dass man die
Meinungsfreiheit bedroht dürfen
vielleicht ja zum Beispiel man könnte
den auch mal sagen kommt mal mit nach
Terenten dann könnt ihr mal sehen wie
das mit der Meinungsfreiheit ist oder
nach Moskau oder aber in unserem eigenen
Land vor 70 80
ich könnte hier sagen straflosse sie von
Trottel haltet für sie nicht durch ist
auch nicht meine Meinungsfreiheit wer
meine Meinung frei ja ich tue ich bin
nicht gefährdet wirklich
Meinungsfreiheit der eine Punkte zweite
ist eben eine meinungsdominanz in den
Medien das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge
also wenn die Bild-Zeitung oder oder der
Spiegel immer zu irgendein bestimmte
Sache sagt dann ist das eine Geschichte
aber das ist ja dann damit ist die
Meinungsfreiheit ja nicht eingeschränkt
ich werde dir nicht gehauen wenn ich
eine andere Meinung habe aber was sie
eben angesprochen haben die gefühlte es
sind ihm sehr viele Menschen die
wahrnehmen sie könnten dass sich das mag
und ich glaube das ist unsicht
zutreffend ist aber für die ist es real
es ist eine reale politische
Einschränkung für diese Menschen obwohl
es vielleicht gar keinen sachlichen
Grund dafür gibt
ja ja das ist aber auch real,-
noch gibt also ein Problem mit der
Meinungsfreiheit wie sie wahrgenommen
wird dass wir auf der anderen Seite ich
sehe das im klimageschäft was im
klimageschäft alles so erzählt wird was
schon vorkommen klar ist dass es mit dem
kipppunkten so und so jedermann weiß
dass sie um die Ecke sind wenn wir nicht
sofort diese jenes machen dass die
Berichterstattung über das Medium
dermaßen einseitig ist wenn ich mir mal
die ARD ansehe zum Beispiel dann wundert
sich schon warum werden kommen da nicht
immer die gleichen Leute zum zum Worten
und nicht mal eine differenzierte oder
vielleicht eine andere Meinung aber das
ist ein anderes Thema das ist über die
Dominanz in den Medien der Spiegel ist
leider vollkommen umgefallen seitdem sie
zusammengelegt worden sind mit SPIEGEL
ONLINE aber und das andere ist die
wahrgenommene Meinungsfreiheit die war
ja die gefühlte dass sie mir in
Wirklichkeit alles sein können und ich
kann auch immer alles sagen mir ist noch
nie was passiert da weil die freche
Sachen gesagt habe das dem stimme ich
ihn Vorkommen zu aber es ist real es ist
Menschen gibt die Angst haben das zu
sagen was sie meint wir gehen das
Schlusswort weil der weil die NZZ die
hat ja auf jeden Fall sagt sie ist
neutral
Schlusswort ich kann es relativ kurz
machen wir haben schon zwei Objektive
Probleme mit der Meinungsfreiheit a im
geisteswissenschaftlichen Bereich an
Universitäten wo bestimmte
Forschungsfelder gar nicht mehr für
forschungsattraktiv gehalten werden
keine Drittmittel mehr eingeworben
werden weil sie nicht dem Geist der
Zeiten entsprechen weil sie nicht der
Mainstreaming des Denkens entsprechend
vor allem der Geisteswissenschaft es
gibt Initiative Geistesfreiheit können
Sie sich anschauen viele Fälle
aufgelistet und zum anderen vergessen
leider die öffentlich rechtlichen Medien
an zu vielen Stellen dass sie vom Gesetz
das Recht haben von allen Menschen die
Deutschland leben Gebühren zu verlangen
dass sie aber nicht in der nötigen
breite die Meinungen aller gebührenzahl
aller Beitragszahl abdecken das ist ein
großes Problem wir haben oft talkshirt
und nicht alle aber oft talkshirten die
nicht Gleichgewichte besetzt sind in
denen nicht verschiedene Meinungen
aufeinander Ukraine ist ein Beispiel
Corona war ein anderes Beispiel und wir
haben vor allen Dingen auch in der
kommen den Kommentaren
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien an vielen
Stellen eine weltansche Schlagseite sein
beispielsweise auch bei der Studie die
ich eben vorgetragen habe über die
Volontäre also für mich wäre es auch
furchtbar wenn jetzt der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk bei
Bewerbern immer fragt welche politische
Richtung haben
nein das war ja eine einzige
Unfallstelle
Ukraine beim öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehen fertig
ist auch ein Feld wo wir lange brauchen
und seine Meinungsfreiheit jetzt
gestellt zu haben aber auch lange nur
ein einarativ möglich also muss man
sagen es war schon lange Zeit ähnliche
bei Corona eine Gefährdung geredet
habe lange Zeit eine sehr einfach dann
habe ich verstanden
nicht ganz einfach man muss einfach eine
Bringschuld öffentlich Rechner auch jene
abzudecken in ihrem Programm die die
konservativ sich ein selbst einrichten
und einsetzen oder vielleicht sogar
rechts und das verfilmte Wort einmal zu
sagen die muss man auch abdecken mit
Position Millionen vielleicht sogar auch
mal mit einem Format wo man von einer
konservativen Watte auf die Welt schaut
und nicht immer nur von linker Seite
also ich glaube die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen brauchen Mut so
Vielfalt und zwar Mut zur
Meinungsvielfalt und wo wir uns heute
Abend alle einig sind hier am Tisch das
mit seiner Meinung sagen darf und das
sollte man tun wir wünschen noch einen
schönen Abend und bis morgen Abend dann
wieder hier bei 8:15
[Musik]